machine living and production isn't it
awesome but what does this reduction
even mean
today I want to talk about buzzwords who
doesn't like them they make a sound
smart they allow us to convey a lot of
information with a single or few amount
of words but they can also introduce
inferential distance and they can be
confusing now buzzwords aren't
fundamentally bad though the term does
sometimes evoke a negative sentiment
they can be dangerous however giving us
the feeling that we understand something
without actually being able to explain
it in simple terms
and I want to talk in this talk about a
specific buzzword that I took for
granted which is production
so to start with the story
I was giving a talk about applying
machine learning in practice and
covering amylops which we all love I
share the obvious notion with my
audience that machine learning models
are not just for research maybe not even
mostly for that and then I asked the
question that I thought was really
simple
if you create a great model but no one
ever uses it in other words it's not
deployed to production does it really
matter
now I thought this would be a great
rhetorical question to start my talk
with but one of the listeners raised
their hands and asked when you say
production what exactly do you mean
and I found myself noticing the
inferential distance I was treating
something vague that seemed clear to me
um asking questions about it taking it
as a given when in fact many data
scientists might have a very different
notion of what production is and this is
how this talk was born
so hi I'm Dean uh thanks for joining my
talk my background is a combination of
physics machine learning and computer
science I am very passionate about
building tools that help machine
learning teams work together I'm strong
believer in open source and the role it
has to play in the world of machine
learning and I am the co-founder of
dagsa which is building a GitHub for
machine learning we take popular open
source tools and combine them into a
platform that makes them easier to use
adding the workflows that are needed for
working on on those tools together
and I'm also the host of the mlops
podcast where I speak with industry
leaders and experts about getting ml
into the real world a new episode just
dropped today so check it out
but back to my question let me ask you
again if you create a great model but no
one uses it does it really matter
now applying a first principles approach
let's define production in the context
of machine learning models for a sec so
putting a machine learning model in
production means that your machine
learning model's predictions or outputs
directly affect some product or user
whether it's by educating them helping
them make decisions or enabling them to
do something they couldn't do before
like creating images of a van Gogh
looking Shakespearean character which
stable diffusion helped me do here
now to put this into a bit of context
there was this famous statistic about 87
percent of models never making it to
production it is wrong probably
um but my reading of the sentence is
that a large part of ml models never
make it to the point where they actually
have an impact on any product or user or
consumer that's a shame so today what I
want to do is make sure that you don't
fall into the specific hole and you have
the right mental model and tool set to
get to the desired land of production
um and now that we've defined what
production is for machine learning
models we can ask another question which
is what types of production are there
when I ask the people of Reddit I got a
bunch of interesting answers so for some
it's a deployed model endpoint and in
this case the deployment might be done
as a Lambda function or whatever
you might build the model into an
application that runs on an edge device
I spoke with a bunch of people that do
that here
um but it might be something entirely
different for some they run a model
locally on a regular Cadence then upload
the predictions as a table to a database
which is queried by their consumers some
people shared that their production is
actually a dashboard that they send out
to management where a machine learning
model is creating some of the
information in that dashboard
and last but not least it might be that
the model is just part of a larger ETL
process and might just create a single
feature in other words your model might
be just another part of a pipeline and I
think this last point is worth diving
into because when we think about machine
learning we usually imagine something
like this sort of a machine learning
model which is a black box with
potentially math magic happening inside
that receives some data and then spits
out a cat dog prediction but in my
experience most times this is a grand
oversimplification of reality and
reality looks more like this
so your model is a sort of de facto data
transformation transformation running as
part of a larger pipeline that might
include pre or post-processing steps as
well as other models
now you might ask why does this small or
arguably small difference matter I think
that first as a different mental model
of what production looks like uh affects
how we think about building production
grade models we need to understand the
relationship between the models that we
train and the data that they're trained
on thinking about the entire system
right starting from the raw data all the
way to the consumption of our model's
predictions this will increase your
productivity by avoiding hacky solutions
that are not actually fit for production
the second reason is that it helps you
better understand your problems and
challenges and the requirements from the
solutions that you're going to choose
you can't solve a problem if you don't
really understand it
so I'm talking a lot about first
principles uh thinking let's just Define
what exactly what that means so what
we're going to do for first principles
thinking is basically discuss the basic
assumptions we have about the problem
then break the problem down into the
smallest irrefutable pieces and try to
build up the solution from those uh
pieces bottom up
so what are what am I assuming here
first I'm assuming that we are deploying
a single model the simplest case for
deployment and this is so that you can
easily understand the process well and
extrapolate it to your use case for
deployment or production later
um we're also going to take the simplest
flow described earlier so you can assume
this like Black Box model contains
multiple steps but they're just all
bundled into one package and if by the
end of this talk you still feel like
what I'm talking about does not apply to
your use case reach out to me I would
honestly love to help you
um and the last thing is I'm not going
to discuss anything that relates to
training that model I'm assuming it's
ready to go and you're now trying to
figure out what to do with it
so how do we break deployment down into
its constituent components from first
principles where I'm going to go over
sort of a theoretical breakdown and then
go over each step and give you some
practical recommendations of how we
think about it so we have our model
ready and the first thing we're going to
do is we're going to need to write a bit
of code a function that wraps this train
model loads it receives the data and
performs the prediction and then returns
that prediction as a function output and
once we did that we can now predict
locally which is pretty awesome the
first time you do it it's exciting right
but we don't only want to predict
locally or only in one language so
usually step two is to build an
interface with real world an API it can
receive some standard format requests
parse the information and send it to our
function and then return the prediction
in another standard format message
now now that we did that we can
communicate with the model in a
universal language and that's awesome
but it's still running locally and we
need to figure out a way for it to be
run in other places we need to have it
not just work on my machine yes this is
a stable diffusion interpretation
um so in other words the third step is
to make sure our API is inside an
environment that makes it portable and
able to run wherever we need it to this
package contains the environment code
API and other requirements so that it
just runs
and once we have that thing we have a
portable environment for our model it
can communicate with the world in a
standardized format which causes our
model to predict and then return that
prediction we're almost there
the last uh and the fourth and final
step is to put this somewhere consumers
can actually use it in other words we
need some infrastructure to host our
container
usually this means the cloud a magical
place where Anything could happen but it
doesn't have to be infrastructure can be
on-prem too or on an edge device in some
cases
so now that we've done that we can
basically use our model from anywhere we
want with a universal language it
triggers it it returns its prediction
it's basically ready to be incorporated
into our product
so to put everything into one slide this
is sort of the four step breakdown of
what deployment is taking a first
principles Approach at this point you
might be asking yourself this is simple
what am I doing here
um but I think that this is awesome
because it means that we no longer need
to solve for production or deployment
there are no longer buzzwords we have
four much more tractable sub problems
that we need to solve and once we solve
all of these problems we are effectively
in the land of production
and now that we have that laid out let
me go over a few recommendations for
each of these steps uh including
recommended tools which people like to
take snapshots of so for step one
recommended tools the correct Choice
here is always the tools you're already
familiar with if possible for most
people this means python tensorflow
pythorg scikit
um but you sometimes do have additional
constraints like the programming
language that you have to use in the end
or support for gpus so it is important
to take those into consideration
I also would encourage you to think
about model portability if that's
something that you care about you might
want to look into portability first
formats like onnx this is especially
important if you deploy to multiple
types of endpoints but as your company
grows you'll want to standardize the
deployment process anyway and a great
way to achieve that is to use a
non-framework specific format for your
models
in a similar vein it is also worth
spending a bit of time defining a
company or team-wide class or interface
for your model's prediction function
this will help with interoperability and
automation as you grow it's really not
that high effort and it has huge
benefits
step two
so here you can use anything from manual
implementation with python requests all
the way to fast API which is my current
favorite they are all great tools and
you can always Google tutorial machine
learning API with X and find great
materials I tried it it works
um it is important to note that some
model consumers require non-flexible
endpoints so some tools that we've
worked with require your prediction
endpoint to be at model URL predict and
they won't accept anything else so you
need to make sure that you know your
consumer's requirements and Implement
them the proper way to save yourself a
lot of pain and effort
and last for this part you should also
consider the context of your deployment
in a distributed microservice
architecture where your model is exposed
to the web I know a lot of buzzwords
um you'll need to implement
authentication for it many times control
who gets access to the prediction and
everything now this is beyond the scope
of this talk but I'll provide some
example reading material uh in the last
slide which I think is important because
a lot of tutorials just gloss over this
and assume you'll just figure it out
for step three my answer is of course
Docker a lot has been said about it but
it's a good idea to have some
understanding of how it works and how to
use it and even if you use something
else it's probably using Docker under
the hood
there are many amazing tools that offer
automatic processes that cover API and
containerization together so steps two
and three and they are great but the
reason they can automate these steps is
because they are making decisions on
your behalf so if you have a very
standard deployment uh use case they can
work but for customization you're
usually going to need to dive a layer
deeper and get into the nitty-gritty of
Docker so it's not really a full
replacement I still recommend you have
the basic understanding of how that
works
last but not least in our final stages
we don't exactly have recommended tools
as much as our necessary deployment
setup so your constraints such as
deploying a microservice endpoint a
Lambda function a pipeline stage or a
user's Edge device will dictate what
you're going to use here
and of course a talk like this cannot be
complete if I don't talk about gpus most
of the infrastructure that exists in the
world isn't targeted towards machine
learning specifically and one of the
main differences is our increased demand
for gpus so working with them is
complicated and sometimes requires
special care and many of the tools that
I mentioned in the previous step also
help you deal with gpus in your
deployment process but you can also find
great content about working with them
directly or via dedicated cloud services
like AWS agemaker
so this is it we've reached the end of
our journey and I want to end with a few
resources for you to take the next step
with each process we usually feel that
it's very easy to take the first step
but the second one is hard so you can
read over these and they cover like it's
one article for each
step
um and that's it thank you for joining
my talk I hope it was useful uh and you
can follow me on Twitter LinkedIn or
reach out to me uh here outside the the
talk I also have swag that I'm very
happy to give you so come talk to me
um yeah thank you
foreign